[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى 360 من العربيه
خدمه اخباريه نتابع فيها الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن كل الجوانب
موسكو تنسخ اسلوبك
يتجول في ماريابل والكريملين يعد ملفا لما
وصفه بجرائم اوكرانيا
ما تزال تعذب جنودها ومدني العراق
ولدينا ايضا
ترفع درجه التاهب البيت الابيض يراقب
الوضع الامني ومدعي عاما يتوعد مخالف
القانون
[موسيقى]
زياره الرسائل هكذا قرات زياره الرئيس
الروسي الاولى الى اقليم دومباس منذ بدء
الحرب بوتين الذي صدرت بحقه مذكره من
الجنائيه الدوليه ويتم تشكيك في اداء قوته
خلال العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا تجول
في ماريوبل في مشهد مشابه لجولات الرئيس
الاوكراني في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه
مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبل اشهر المدن
الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكراني
يعلوه على مر الروسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات
كثيره الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي
تشكل رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب
اوكرانيا الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار
المعارك المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره
المفاجئه تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق
التي استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرن وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا
الملك تاتي زياره قبل زياره مرتقبه لشي
جين بينج حليف بوتين الابرز وفي وقت يتكتل
فيه حلفاء كييف الغربيون لدعم هجومها
المرتقب في الربيع هجوم تقول انها تريد من
خلاله استعاده اراضيها المسلوبه ما بينما
استولت عليه موسكو وما تريده كييف وقف
بوتي وقفه قال فيها الكثير وان لم يتحدث
رائد المصطفى العربيه
ونتابع مع حضراتكم التطورات هيئه الاشراف
على السوق الماليه السويسريه هناك عمليه
انتقال لكريدي سويس ستتضمن استقرار
الاسواق في ضوء الاجراءات التي يتم
التعامل معها لاحتواء الازمه المتعلقه
بانهيار بنك سيليكون فالي هناك اجراءات
الان تتم لمحاوله السيطره على هذه الازمه
بحيث لا يتم اسقاط بنوك اخرى في فخ
الافلاس وهو امر قد صارت بشانه العديد من
المخاوف من ان يؤدي الى ازمه ماليه عالميه
شبيهه بعام 2008 هيئه الاشراف على السوق
الماليه السويسريه تقول ان عمليه الانتقال
الخاصه بكريدي سويس ستتضمن استقرار
الاسواق وهو اجراء لطمانه
الموضعين والبنوك ايضا في نفس الوقت
ونعود مره اخرى لمتابعه التطورات الخاصه
بزياره الرئيس بوتين الى ماريوبل وينضم
الينا الدبلوماسيه الروسي السابق فيتشيلاك
ماتزوف مرحبا بك سيد هناك اسئله تتعلق
لماذا قرر بوتين زياره ماريوبل في هذا
التوقيت تحديدا وهل للتوقيت دلاله
طبعا انا اقول لكم رايي الشخصي ان هذا
الزياره زياره مهمه للغايه بسبب واحد انه
روسيا بعد اصدار هذا القرار
محكمه دوليه بين القرصين لان هذا ليست
محكمه دوليه هذا
وموافقه عليها
اداره الامريكيه التي ترفض اساسا النتائج
العامه لهذه المحكمه بين لقوسين سابقا
عندما كانت محاوله اتهام بجرائم الحرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ورئيس امريكي
ولذلك اليوم برايي انا بوتين اخذ قرار
الحاسم ام فعلا ان يعملوا الحرب حقيقيه
وليست حرب مثلما هو كان سابقا جزئيا ضد
قوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذا اولا شيء
ثاني ما الذي يقوم بحرب
حرب حقيقيه او حرب كامله كما تقصد ما الذي
يعنيه هذا التعبير
في اوساط الروسيه يعتبرون ان ما كان يجري
هذا ليست حربا حقيقيا لان اوقفوا
لمده معينه انسحبوا لمده معينه من كيف من
حرقه نتيجه الرغبه
اداره سياسيه في روسيا لكي يفتحوا الباب
للمفاوضات مع الاتراك
ماركان ما الفرنسا وفتحوا البابلي صفقه
القمح
بالقليل هذا
يحضر شركات الامريكيه تملك ثلثين من تلك
القمح اوكرانيا هذا ملك
لشركه
زراعيه
امريكيه ليس اوكرانيه لذلك كل هذه
توقف بعم العسكريه خلال السنه الماضيه
كثير من
محللين الروس كان يعتبرون هذا غير طبيعي
اذا بدات الحرب لازم تطابعوا الحرب حتى
توصل الى اهدافها ولذلك هذا قرارات مختلطه
بين السياسه بين مفاوضات
واعمال العسكريه كانت دائما يثير الشكوك
كبيره في ارشاد ليست فقط مدنيين ولكن
بالنسبه لهذه الفكره ان الحرب المستمره
وستكون شامله ارجو ان تبقى معي سيد متوزوف
سنتابع ايضا العديد من التطورات
الاخرى سفير الروسي لدى برلين سيرجي
نيتشوب تصريحات بعض المسؤولين الالمان حول
تاييد قرار المحكمه الجنائيه بانها مصدر
قلق بالغ كان وزير العدل الالماني مركوب
وشمال تعهد باعتقال بوتين في حال قرر
الاخير زياره المانيا
من جهته حضر رئيس صربي من عواقب سياسيه
سيئه لقرار الجنائيه الدوليه واكد انه
يقوض فرص السلام والهدنه في اوكرانيا
واطلق الكويت شي اعتقد ان قرار اصدار
مذكره توقيف في حق بوتين ستكون له عواقب
سياسيه سيئه ووخي مع الحياه الناس مع
الحديث ان هناك احجاما كبيرا عن التطرق
الى السلام والهدنه لانقاذ حياه الكثيرين
السؤال بعد ان اتهم بارتكاب جرائم حرب الى
من سيتم التحدث الان الجميع ينتظر الهزيمه
لكن كم سنه سننتظر وهل من الممكن هزيمه
روسيا في شهر او ثلاثه او حتى سنه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اصدرت
مذكره ب لكن لا يزال بامكانه زياره العديد
من البلدان نظريا يعزل قرار المحكمه بوتين
عن ثلثي العالم لكن مع وجود 193 دوله عضوا
في الامم المتحده بمقدور الرئيس الروسي
بوتين زياره 70 دوله على الاقل غير خاضعه
لقرار المحكمه مثل ماذا الصين اكبر حلفاء
روسيا ومن المرجح ان ترحب بزياره بوتين
خاصه وان نظيره الصيني سيلتقيه في موسكو
قريبا ايضا يستطيع بوتين الذهاب الى ايران
وهي حليف رئيسي لروسيا تؤكد تقارير عده
انها زودتها بطائرات بدون طيار لمجهودها
الحربي الهند بدورها ايضا ليست من الدول
الموقعه على قانون المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه ولم تدم يوما التدخل الروسي في
اوكرانيا بل ان نيودلهي عززت العلاقات مع
موسكو في تلك الفتره بالحديث عن حرب
اوكرانيا تبقى بيلاروسيا داعمه روسيا في
هذه الحرب مع سماح رئيسها الاكساندر
لوكيشنكو للقوات الروسيه باستخدام
بيلاروسيا كنقطه انطلاق للحرب كذلك يحتفظ
بوتين بعلاقات قويه مع دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق مثل ارمينيا اذربيجان
اضافه للجمهوريه الخمس في اسيا الوسطى
اعود مره اخرى الى موسكو والدبلوماسي
الروسيه
هناك تساؤل كبير حول القادم بالنسبه
لبوتين بعد قرار المحكمه هل هذا القرار في
المستقبل يمكن ان يؤثر على الوضع السياسي
لبوتين اذا ما انتهت هذه الحرب بمعنى ان
يكون معرض لان يتم
تعقبه بشكل كبير اعتقاله في اي لحظه في اي
جوله خارجيه هل تتعامل روسيا مع هذا
السيناريو
قوات المسلحه لاي دوله
يمكن ان يعمل اي
مهاجمه على موقف او مركز او وجود الرئيس
الروسي في اي دوله من الدول العالم انا لا
تصور كيف وين ياخذ قوات المسلحه لكي
يستولوا على الرئيس الروسي لذلك هذا
المحكمه الدوليه هذا المحكمه غير شرعيه
بوجهه النظر الروسيه روسيا ترفض رافضه
انقطعا وجوده محكمه وعندي سؤال اي مؤسسه
دوليه اذا هي تعمل في اثار الام المتحده
تعتمد على قوانين الدوليه على دستور الامم
المتحده محكمه دوليه تابعه للام المتحده
موجود جنبا لجانب لمحكمه هذا الجنائيا
ولذلك هناك سؤال كبير
هو انتخبه وعينه لدوله
الحقوقيين او هؤلاء الحكماء
يصدروا هذا الحكم اولا شيء ثاني هذا
المحكمه دوليه اذا تابع لام المتحده يعني
ام المتحده تمول موظفين في هذا
محكمه دوليه ولكن اذا هذا المحكمه دوليه
ليست وليده اليوم
ولكن مع الاسف شديد انا شخصيا اعتبر ان
الروسي
ارتكبت الغلطه عندما ما ادانا نشاد هذه
المحكمه عندما
يتاقلوا
وبعد موته في السجن هاك وجدوا انه هو مبرر
ان ليست
روسيا ملفا للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كرد
على هذه الخطوه لان كانت هناك فيديوهات
تحدثت فيها روسيا عن انه تم انتهاك حقوق
الانسان بالنسبه للاسرى من الجنود الروسي
هل تتحركون في هذا الجانب
انا لا اتصور انا روسيا تتلاعب او تتنافس
مع امريكا ومع دول غربيه في انشاء نفس
المؤسسات
الشرائيه او
تحقيقيه باي شكل لدي الروسيا امكانيه ان
يرد على طريق واحده براي انا شخصي هذا
انتشار الكامل وشامل خلال عمليه عسكريه
روسيه في اوكرانيا هذا هذا اصطدام مع نفس
الدول الغربيه مجموعه من اكثر من خمسين
دوله الذي هي تحارب اليوم روسيا فيدراليه
في اوكرانيا على راسه تلك المجموعه دول
ولايات المتحده انتصار في اوكرانيا هذا
سيكون ردا وطرف منتشر هو يؤلف اي نوع
المحاكم محكمه وكذلك هناك جرائم كبرى لديه
سلطه اوكرانيه تستحق اهتمام على
تحقيقات والجنائيه شاك ضربه ثمانيه سنوات
المدينه المدنيه
الروسيه السابق من موسكو تحياتي
[موسيقى]
اصدرت مصر والاردن والولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وسلطه الفلسطينيه بيانا مشتركا
بشان اجتماع اليوم في شرم الشيخ واكد
البيان على ضروره تحقيق الهدنه على الارض
ووقف العنف بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
كما جددت اسرائيل وسلطه الفلسطينيه
التاكيد على وقف الاجراءات الاحاديه لفتره
ما بين ثلاثه الى سته اشهر مع وقف مناقشه
المستوطنات الجديده لمده اربعه اشهر قادمه
ايضا اعلن البيان عن استحداث اليه لوقف
العنف والتحريض مع رفع تقارير الى قيادات
دول الخمس مع ضروره ضمان مواجهه اي
استفزازات في المواقع المقدسه بما في ذلك
خلال شهر رمضان كما اكد البيان ارساء اليه
من اجل تحسين الوضع الاقتصادي للشعب
الفلسطيني البيان واكد ايضا ان اسرائيل
وسلطه الفلسطينيه اتفقا على الالتزام بكل
الاتفاقيات السابقه بينهما كما تقرر
استمرار الاجتماعات على المستوى الخماسي
من اجل وضع اساس لاجراء مفاوضات مباشره
للتواصل الى سلام
هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقال منافذ
هجوم اليوم على بلده حواره في نابلس بصفه
الغربيه بعد اصابته واصفر الهجوم عن اصابه
مستوطنين اثنين حاله احدهما خطيره في
البلده التي تشهد توترا كبيرا في الاونه
الاخيره
والى شان داخليه الاسرائيليه حيث اعلنت
محكمه العدل العليا منع وزير الامن القومي
بالجفير من اعطاء تعليمات عمليه للشرطه
خصوصا اثناء الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه واكدت
المحكمه ان هذا المنع ضروري من اجل تجنب
النزعه في المستقبل كما انها تمنع
التوجيهات السياسيه للشرطه خلال حدث لا
يزال جاريا وقالت المحكمه ان اعطاء
تعليمات بشان كيفيه استخدام القوه في مثل
هذا الحدث امر لا يخص وزير الامن القومي
منجاته طلب رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
مكتب الموضعي العام وسلطات المختصه بتصرف
بشكل حاسم ضد من يحرض على قتله وعائلته
والوزراء واعضاء الكنيست
لن نقبل الفوضى ومطالبه البعض بقطع الطرق
ومنظر الدماء في الشوارع وايضا تعرض
الشخصيات العامه للاذى لن نقبل بالعنف من
اي جانب اتوقع من قاده الشرطه تطبيق
القانون لمنع العنف وعوده الحياه الى
طبيعتها وان يتصرف مكتب المدعي العام بشكل
حاسم ضد الذين يحرضون على قتل الوزراء
واعضاء الكنيست وقتل رئيس الوزراء وعائلته
فالدوله التي تريد الحياه لا تستطيع ان
تتحمل مثل هذه الظواهر ولن نتحملها يجب ان
تكون هناك مناقشه حقيقيه وموضوعيه وعادله
للاصلاح القانوني
هذا وتتزايد التحديات وجه خطط نتنياهو
لتعديل القضاء حيث اعلن المئات من جنود
الاحتياط وحدات النخبه العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه انهم لن يحضروا بعض
الواجبات المكلفين بها من اليوم بينما حذر
نتنياهو من ان لا حياه لاسرائيل اذا رفضت
الخدمه بالجيش
ومن الناصره ينضم الينا نظير مجلي المحلل
السياسي مرحبا بك سيد مجلي ما هو القادم
في اسرائيل وفقا لهذه التطورات هل نتحدث
عن حرب اهليه عن انقلاب عسكري عن قدره على
احتواء الازمه اي الخيارات هو الاكثر
وقوعا في ظل هذه التطورات
المشاهدين والمشاهدات الصحيح من الصعب ان
نحدد بالضبط اي اتجاهات هنالك معركه جديه
كبيره قويه تسير ما بين حكومه اليمين
المتطرف في اسرائيل من جهه وبين ممثليين
الدوله العميقه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
التي ترى ان المساله ليست مساله اصلاحات
قضائيه فحسب الانقلاب على كل منظومه الحكم
في اسرائيل سوف تتناول ايضا المساس
بالاعلام المساس بحريه الراي ممارسه ضغوط
على اجهزه الامن وسحب صلاحيات معينه منها
والعديد العديد من الاجراءات الاخرى التي
تتجاوز القضيه القضائيه
وفي قياده الطرفين توجد نوع صلبه تسر على
المضي قدما كل في مشاريعها من جهه الخطه
الحكوميه ومن جهه اخرى تلك القوى الجديه
عندما نقول الدوله العميقه يعني نقصد ايضا
الجيش ونقصد المخابرات ونقصد الشرطه ونقصد
جهاز الحاكم في اعماق اعماق الدوائر
الحكوميه والدوائر البحثيه في اسرائيل
كلها مجتمعه للتصدي لمثل هذه المحاولات
التي تعتبر ان معركه رئيس الاسرائيلي
وربما هو منصب شرفي ولكنه حاول ان يدخل
على خط الازمه بطرح مبادره لمحاوله الجمع
ما بين الحكومه والمعارضه هذه المبادره لن
تنجح حتى اللحظه ولكن هل يمكن ان تنجح وهل
يمتلك الرئيس اليات اخرى لتغيير هذا
الموقف كحل او مطالبه الحكومه بالاستقاله
مثلا من الممكن ان تنج
ح في قوه
مختلفه ولكن
الدوله العميقه التي تحارب هذه الظاهره لا
ترى ان هنالك حلولا وسط في الاعتداء على
الديمقراطيه ولذلك نراها انها مصره على ان
تكمل في هذه الاجراءات حتى لو اتخذت وقتا
طويلا لعده سنوات الى حين يطاح في حكم
اليمين هذه القوه ترى ان هذه فرصه لان
اليمين اليوم في اسرائيل لاول مره في
تاريخه يحكم لوحده في اسرائيل ولا يوجد
لديه حلول للقضايا الجوهريه التي تعانيها
اسرائيل وليس فقط
لم تكن مطروحه من قبل نحن نتحدث على ما
يمكن توصيفه بتمرد داخل الجيش برفض داخل
الشرطه لمحاوله قمع المحتجين هناك تحول
كبير في المؤسسات الحكوميه الاسرائيليه
ليس لصالح هذه الحكومه
نعم بالتاكيد القوه التي تنزل الى الشارع
وتتظاهر ضد هذه الحكومه لم تكن في تاريخها
ولا حد كان يتخيل ان تنزل تصوري انه نتحدث
عن خمسه مفتشين عامين للشرطه سابقا رؤساء
اركان الجيش ينزلون ويتظاهرون ان الصلبه
التي تقود هذه المعركه ضد الحكومه تضم
عددا من القوى الاساسيه في الجيش
والمخابرات اضافه الى القوى الاخرى
يريد ان يتراجعوا ولكن لديه قضيه شخصيه
تعيق عليه يعني نتنياهو في كل هذه المعركه
لم يكن يريد ولكن لانه موجود في محكمه
محاكمه شخصيه في قضايا الفساد حاول ان
يضغط على المحكمه العليا وعلى كل جهاز
القضاء على امل ان يتراجعوا عن محاكمته
ولكنه اصطدم بقوه اخرى اضافه الى المحاكم
في الشارع اشكرك على هذا التحميل نعم سيد
نظير مجلي المحلل السياسي من الناصره شكرا
شكرا لك
وفي العربيه 300 بعد هذا الفاصل
دراسه للبنتاجون تؤكد ارتفاع معدلات
الاصابه بالسرطان بين تيار القوات الجويه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
في الذكرى العشرين للحرب الامريكيه في
العراق كشف عميل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
الامريكيه جورجي بيرو تفاصيل مثيره عما
ضرب بينه وبين الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام
حسين خلال التحقيق معه غدا اعتقاله المحقق
الامريكي اكد في تصريحات الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان صدام حسين لم يكن يملك اسلحه
دمار شامل وهي ذريعه التي استعملها الرئيس
السابق جورج بوش لدخول العراق سنه 2003
[موسيقى]
علماني جدا اظهرت تدينه لكي يتم اعتباره
شخصيه مهمه في تاريخ العرب لم يكن يملك
اسلحه دمار شامل قبل غزو بوش للعراق ولم
تكن له علاقه بالقاعده بل كان لا يؤمن
بايديولوجيهها ولا يحب زعيمها انه الرئيس
العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين بروايه كتاب
المحقق الامريكي جورج بيرو الذي استجوبه
عقب غزو العراق قبل عقدين من الزمن سبعه
اشهر من الاستجواب ولساعات يوميا فتره
طويله كانت كفيله لتفصح لعميل مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي الامريكي عما يدور في
ذهن صدام حسين
بيرو قال انه لعب على حبل الزمن بعدها اسر
صدام حسين ان همه الاكبر لم يكن الولايات
المتحده ولا اسرائيل بل كان ايران لذلك
كان يدعي انه يمتلك اسلحه دمار شامل او
كان غامضا بشانها لردع الايرانيين عن غزو
العراق
المحقق الامريكي افصح ايضا ان صدام حسين
لم يكن متفاجئا من غزو الولايات المتحده
للعراق فقد ادرك ان الحرب حتميه بحلول
اكتوبر او نوفمبر من العام 2002
بيرو تحدث ايضا مع صدام حسين عن روايته
زبيبه والملك التي صدرت سنه 2000 قائلا
انها تشبيه منه لحال الشعب العراقي والقوه
الامريكيه وصدام الملك المنقذ
المحقق الاميركي خلص الى ان احد اكبر
اخفاقات الولايات المتحده تفكيك الجيش
العراقي فالعراق الان بحاجه لرجل يضع
البلد في اولوياته وهو ما فعله صدام حسين
يقول المحقق جورج بيرو بلال البجدين
العربيه
العراق
طالب بريمر حامل اسرار العراق لعقدين من
الزمن يعترف لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط بارتكاب
خطاين رئيسيين ضمن المهمه التي اصدر
خلالها مئه من المراسيم اولها اجتهاث
تفكيك البعث والثاني حل الجيش العراقي
لكنه بالرغم من ذلك اصر على صوابيه قرار
الحرب وضروره الاطاحه بصدام حسين وبحسب
بريمير مهما كان وضع العراق فانه يبقى
افضل حالا بعد عشرين عاما برحيل صدام
مضيفا انه لو بقي صدام في السلطه لاصبح
العالم امام قوتين نوويتين على الاقل هما
ايران والعراق
خلصت دراسه اجرتها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البينتاجون الى ارتفاع معدلات الاصابه
بالسرطان بين تيار القوات الجويه الدراسه
اظهرت لاول مره ان افراد الطواقم الارضيه
الذين يزودون طائرات العسكريه بالوقود
ويعملون على صيانتها والاشراف على
انطلاقها يصابون بالمرض ايضا وفي الدراسه
التي استمرت لمده عام على ما يقرب من 900
الف فرد من العسكريين الذين قضوا طائرات
بين عامي
1992 و 2017
تواصلت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه الى وجود
معدلات اعلى بكثير للاصابه بسرطانات الجلد
والغده الدرقيه والدماغ والبروستاتا
والثدي
20 عاما تمر على الحرب الامريكيه في
العراق والاثار الصحيه على سكان محافظه
صلاح الدين ما تزال باقيه نتحدث عن قاعده
بلد اكبر قاعده جويه في العراق والتي تبعد
64 كيلو مترا الى الشمال من العاصمه بغداد
خلال ذروه العمليات عام 2011 استضافت
القاعده 36 الفا من الافراد العسكريين
والمتعاقدين المدنيين فيها للتخلص من
مخلفات القاعده العسكريه والتي كانت معضله
وجد لها حل قائم على حرقها في حفر حرق على
مدار الساعه حفره الحرق في قاعده بلد كانت
الاكبر في العراق امتدت على مساحه تقترب
من عشره ابنه تم فيها حرق ما يقرب من 150
طنا من النفايات يوميا قدمت
متكرره للبنتاجون حول معلومات المواد التي
تم حرقها الا ان الوزاره قالت انها لا
تحتفظ بسجلات واضحه حول المواد المحروقه
الاثار الصحيه ظهرت على الجنود بالفعل في
قاعده بلد وايضا على السكان المحليين
دراسه امريكيه وجدت ان سبعه في المئه من
الجنود العائدين من بلد عانوا من امراض
الجهاز التنفسي المعاناه طالت ايضا اهالي
بلد الذين ارتفعت بينهم نسب الاصابه
بالربو وانواع مختلفه اخرى من السرطان دون
ان يوجد لدى الكثير منهم تاريخ مرضي سابق
او عوامل مساعده على الجانب الاخر وبين
وبعد عقدين من الزمن وقع رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن العام الماضي تشريعا يقر بالفعل
بوجود صله محتمله بين حفر الحرق والامراض
التي تعرض لها الجنود ليتم شمول اكثر من
200 الف جندي وم تعاقد مدني امريكي بفوائد
الرعايه الصحيه
ونحن نفتح مع حضراتكم هذا الملف للنقاش
وينضم الينا من بغداد الباحث في الشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه العراقيه السيد معن
الجبوري مرحبا بك سيد معا نحن امام تقارير
مهمه للغايه يعترف الامريكان بانهم اصيبوا
بهذه الامراض الصدريه نتيجه حرق الوثائق
ماذا عن العراقيين
تابع يومك سيدتي والساده المشاهدين
واضح انها هذه انعكاسات
لمواد التي استعملت في
ضرب
الضربات الامريكيه التي كانت موجهه منذ
وما تلاها من عمليات تمت باسلحه خاصه هناك
كثير من المعالجات التي تمت باسلحه غير
تقليديه وهذه موثقه موجوده
لدى كثير من المنظمات الدوليه ولكن حقيقه
لم يتم تفعيلها على الاقل من الجانب
العراقي الجانب العراقي دفع ثمنا غاليا
خلال هذا العشرين عام 20 سنه عجاف عاش
اكثر من مليون
شهيد وقتيل مليون ارمله مليون
تحديدا في في واقعه في في قاعده بلد لان
الحديث كان عن حرق مخلفات لهذه القاعده
ادى الى عمليات حرق طويله اصابت الجنود
انفسهم بامراض تنفسيه ولكن هذه القاعده
كان هناك ايضا سكان من العراقيين يعيشون
في محوثها ماذا حدث لهم
حتما اولا اصيبت امراض غريبه كانت تظهر
امراض ليس فقط تنفسيه امراض جلديه امراض
تنفسيه امراض نفسيه من الناحيه
السيكولوجيه هذه ناعيه مهمه جدا
سيدتي هناك انعكاسات امراض نفسيه غريبه
ايضا ظهرت حتى تشوهات خلقيه حصلت وان كان
الحديث عن بلد ولكن في بلد وفي مدن اخرى
تمت ايضا فيها استعمال بعض الاسلحه
التكتيكيه الخاصه لذلك
انعكست هذه على سكان المنطقه بشكل واضح
ومباشر
واضطر الكثير من اهالي المنطقه الى النزوح
الى رغم ان حياتهم مرتبطه جدليا ومعاشيا
بيئيا
بمناطق يمكن توثيق هذه الحالات سيد معا
للاستفاده بها من خلال المطالبات بتعويضات
على امريكا لصالح العراقيين نحن نتحدث عن
من تضرروا خاصه ان الرئيس جو بايدن اعترف
بذلك وشمل بالرعايه الصحيه الجنود
الامريكيين ماذا عن العراقيين الذين
ادفعوا ثمنا ايضا اينما طالب الحكومه
العراقيه في هذا الشان
هذه يجب ان تقوم بها منظمات مهمه وفاعله
حقيقه كثير من الاهالي يفتقرون الى هذه
الثقافه ان يقدم دعوه ضد الجانب الامريكي
ويعلم بانه يحصل على تعويضات
ومحاوله يحصل الى علاج في دول متطوره
سيذكر مثل بسيط في هذا الجانب على مدى 20
عام رغم هذه الانتهاكات التي حصلت
والخروقات
واعترفت امريكا لانها اخطات في تقديراتها
حيث العراق لا توجد بها اسلحه كيميائيه او
بيولوجيه او جرثوميه وغيرها حتى الان لم
تقدم مذكره واحده ضد الجانب الامريكي
بمقاضره امريكا في حين الروس عندما قاموا
بضرب
واجتياح بعض المناطق في اوكرانيا وهي
مناطق حدوديه بالنسبه لهم وفيها مشاكل تمت
ادانه
الرئيسيه في تقديم هذه الدعوه عن هل على
المواطنين العراقيين العاديين الذين لا
يمتلكون كما ذكرت حضرتك الان القدره على
هذا الامر ام على اجهزه الحكومه التي يجب
ان تتحرك
الحكومه كثير من الاحزاب المتنفذه في
السلطه حقيقه لا ترغب باثاره هذه المواضيع
سيدتي لانها تستفيد من الظرف الراهن
مستفيده من المتغير مستفيده من الظرف
الحالي لانها لا تمتلك المال والجاه
والسلاح والسلطه ولا تريد ان تخلق حاله
استفزاز مع الجانب الامريكي لا تريد ان
تثير
هذا الخصم الذي تعمل على تهدئه الاوضاع من
جانبها اتجاهه لكي لا تثير حفيظته لذلك
المنظمات الدوليه هنا بصراحه منظمات
الدوليه المثقفون المحامون منظمات المجتمع
المدني هذه كلها يجب ان تمارس دورها في
مساعده هؤلاء الناس لان هؤلاء ضحايا
ابرياء يعني دفعوا ثمنا غاليا لاخطاء لم
تكن موجوده على الارض
لسيناريوهات اختل قت من قبل الحكومات
الامريكيه السابقه وتحديدا حكومه الرئيس
الامريكي
يشعر ان هناك اهدار للفرص يتم بشكل كبير
كما ذكرت حضرتك هناك ضحايا لهذه الممارسات
هل المسؤوليه تقع على المجتمع المدني فقط
في هذا التوقيت
لا طبعا هي الحكومه مسؤوليه كبيره ولكن
انا ذكرت ان الحكومه لا تريد الحكومات
المتعاقبه طبعا منذ عشرين سنه وحتى
الحكومات الحاليه لا تريد استفزاز هذا
الجانب ليس فقط المنظمه الدوليه هذا هذا
شيء من منظمات الدوليه سيدتي هناك منظمات
دوليه فاعله في العراق تعتاش على مشاكل
العراقيين يعني كثير على سبيل المثال يعني
لدينا السيده بلاس كارت ممثله الامم
المتحده في العراق منذ سنوات تصول وتجول
وتعرف كل شارده ووارده في العراق تدخل في
ادق التفاصيل للحياه اليوميه للمواطنين
عليها ان تقدم النصح تقدم المساعده ودائما
عندما تذهب وتقدم
تقاريرها ضد الحكومه العراقيه ضد
السياسيين العراقيين تنتقدهم بشكل واضح
وصريح ولكن هذا الجانب حقيقه مهمل لم تثر
يعني امكانيه ان يقدم المواطن العراقي لان
هذا هذه الثقافه كما ذكرت غير متوفره في
الشارع العراقي ولا يعتقد انها ممكن اذا
كان من المذهل ان من المؤسف ان الاعلام
الامريكي والسينما الامريكيه هي التي جسدت
هذه المعاناه وهذه الاخطاء الامريكيه بشكل
كبير على يد حال الحديث سيبقى مفتوحا
دائما حول تداعيات الحرب الامريكيه على
العراق من بغداد الباحث في شؤون السياسيه
والامنيه العراقيه سيد معاني الجابوري
شكرا لك لوجودك معنا على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
وقع العراق اتفاقيه امنيه مشتركه مع ايران
بهدف تنسيق لحمايه الحدود بين البلدين
وتوطيط التعاون في مجالات امنيه عده رئيس
الوزراء العراقيه محمد السوداني خلال
لقائه مع رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الايراني
علي شمخاني اكد موقف بلاده الرافض لان
تكون الاراضي العراقيه منطلقا للاعتداء
على اي من دول الجوار مراسل العربيه اوضح
ان اتفاق بغداد وتهران شمل محاربه تهريب
المخدرات من ايران باتجاه العراق كما ينص
على ضبط الحدود بين اقليم كردستان وايران
واشار مراسلنا الى اتفاق العراق وايران
على زياده عدد المخافر الحدوديه بين
البلدين
[موسيقى]
هذا هو من المقرر ان يكشف رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الاسبق بورجونسون عن ادله ضمن
دفاعه عن نفسه امام تحقيق البرلماني في
مجلس العموم يوم الاربعاء بشان اتهامات
بتضليله المجلس حول حفلات خرقت اجراءات
مواجهه فيروس كورونا والتي عرفت اعلاميا
باسم فضيحه
[موسيقى]
بورس جونسون وفضيحه حفلات كورونا الفريق
القانوني لجونسون يضع اللمسات الاخيره على
دفاعه ازاء تضليل البرلمان
ملف الدفاع سيتضمن رسائل من مستشاريه
الذين ابلغوه بانه لم ينتهك قواعد الحج
مصدر مقرب من جونسون الوزراء والمسؤولون
يقراون ما يتم اطلاعهم عليه ويثقون بنصائح
مستشارهم معارضوا جونسون يرون انه كان
ينبغي ان يعرف بعض الاحداث التي حضرها
والتي كسرت اجراءات الاغلاق
يوم الاثنين الموعد النهائي لتقديم دفاع
جونسون بشكل مكتوب
لجنه الامتيازات ستعقد جلسه استماع متلفزه
مباشره يوم الاربعاء
360 توجيه تهم الارهاب لرئيس وزراء
باكستان السابق عمران خان والعشرات من
مساعديه وانصاره
[موسيقى]
قلم مستشار الامن القومي في البيت الابيض
جون كيربي انه لم يتم تهديدات امنيه بعد
دعوه
البيت الابيض لا يريد تكرار احداث اسدس من
يناير حينما اقتحم انصار ترامب مبنى
الكونجرس الامريكي
دعوه واحده من الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ترامب كانت كفيله بان تفتح باب جدل واسع
رئيس الامريكي السابق اعلن انه يتوقع
القاء القبض عليه الثلاثاء في منهجه خلال
مثوله امام المحكمه وحتى انصاره على
الاحتجاج رغم كونها مجرد توقعات من ترامب
حسب ما اكد المتحدث باسمه فان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق فضل ان يقدم على ضربه
استباقيه بالفعل اتت المرجوه منها
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي السابق جون
بولتون نصح المدعي العام بعدم الاقدام على
اتهام ترامب الا ان كان متاكدا للغايه من
التهم الموجهه له لافتا الى ان براءه
ترامب ستسجل في التاريخ على انها كانت
التهمه التي اكسبته كرسي الرئاسه مجددا
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بينس
اعتبر ان توجيه الاتهام المحتمل من مدعي
عام مقاطعه منهات الى الرئيس
سليمان مراسله العربيه مرحبا
دعينا في الاجواء لديك في امريكا ريتا هل
نحن امام صوره قريبه من احداث اسدس من
يناير بمعنى استجابه انصار ترامب لدعوته
للنزول ماذا عن الاجراءات التي اتخذتها
الشرطه الامريكيه كيف تبدو الصوره لديك
بالطبع هناك اجواء مشحونه نوعا ما سياسيا
بعد تصريح الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب عن
احتمال ان يتم اعتقاله يوم الثلاثاء
المقبل اتت هناك ردود افعال سياسيه كثيره
حول هذا الخبر تحديدا بالاضافه الى تحرك
على في جانب مؤيدي الرئيس ترامب
هناك
استعدادات للنزول الى الشارع ولكن بصوره
هادئه مختلفه تماما عن التي كنا نراها في
التي رايناها في السادس من يناير الجميع
يحافظ على كلمات محدده يقولونها ان كان
الرئيس ترامب عندما دعا الى التظاهر هي
كلمه غامضه بعد بعض الشيء لانه لها معنى
يان في اللغه الامريكيه ان كان التظاهر
بشكل سلمي او حتى التظاهر بشكل عنيف فهو
كان يقصد ان يستخدم هذه الكلمه لانه يعرف
ان لها تبعات كثيره في السياسه وسمعنا
تصريحات من مسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه
ومن الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي تعلق
على هذه الكلمه امام الناحيه مؤيدين ترامب
فقالوا انهم مستعدون للنزول الى الشارع
والتظاهر بشكل سلمي وشددوا على هذه الكلمه
ردود الفعل السياسيه التي اتت على هذا
الخبر الذي فجروا بالامس الرئيس دونالد
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اتت من قبل
جمهوريين وديمقراطيين الجمهوريين اعتبروا
بانه هذا استخدام مسيء للسلطه ضد وهو
سياسي والرساله سياسيه موجهه ضد الرئيس
ترامبو ابرز من تحدثهم رئيس مجلس النوابن
ماكارتي بالاضافه الى مايك بانس نائب
الرئيس السابق نائب رئيس دونالد ترامب
تحديدا كان له تصريح بارز في احدى
المقابلات قال بانه هذا تصرف سياسي هذا
موقف المدعي العامه احتماليه التوجيه
التهم للرئيس ترامب واستدعاءه هي خطوه
تفوح منها
رائحه سياسيه بامتياز ايضا كان هناك
موقف لافت لنانسيبي لوسي
رئيسه مجلس النواب السابقه التي اعتبرت
بانه ترامب هو نفسه يستمر بافعاله الشنيعه
واستخدامه عباره التظاهر لها معنى مختلف
ويريد ان يشحن الشارع
سريعا الى اي مدى الى اي مدى خلق هذا
الامر تعاطف مع
الشارع الامريكي دعوته لانصاري للنزول
قوله انه سيعتقل يوم الثلاثاء هل جعل
الجمهور او الراي العام الامريكي يتعاطف
معه ام يتخذ موقفا ضده
من هو مؤيد له بقي مؤيد له وهو
يعول كثيرا على هؤلاء تحديدا الرئيس ترامب
وهو يقول دائما بانه مؤيديه سيؤيدوه لو
مهما حصل لو مهما فعل وهذا كان واضح في
عده مناسبات الان من يخالفه الراي
اتخذ جانب الحذر كثيرا في هذه المساله
لانه يعرف انها مساله سياسيه وسيستخدمها
في الانتخابات نعم شكرا لزميلها سليمان
مراسله العربيه من واشنطن
وجاءت الشرطه الباكستانيه هامات الرئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران من مساعديه وعشرات
من انصاره بالارهاب اضافه الى جرائم اخرى
تتعلق باشتباك عدد منهم مع قوات الامن في
اسلام اباد السبت خلال محاوله اعتقال
عمران خان
في تصريح اليوم نعود فيه بتاريخ الى 20
عاما مضت ما نقدمه لكم اليوم هو حقائق
واستنتاجات تستند الى معلومات مخابراتيه
قويه التصريح هو لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاسبق كوليباول حول مباراه الحرب على
العراق تاريخه في العشرين من يناير 2003
وبعد اكثر من عقد اتى الرد الاكثر وضوحا
من تقرير لجنه السير جون سلكتون في
بريطانيا والذي رد فيه على المزاعم
الاستخباراتيه حول تطوير العراق لاسلحه
دمار شامل بقوله انها كانت معيبه
وفيديو اليوم ايضا يعود الى عامين 2002
و2003 حيث ضجت الشوارع حول العالم رفضا
للحرب الامريكيه على العراق هتافات بكل
اللغات تقريبا ترفض الحرب لكنها لم تجد
اذان صغيره
وصوره اليوم رغم انها كانت حربا مستنده
على مغالطات او حتى اكاذيب كما يفضل البعض
تسميتها لكنها كانت تحمل ايضا في طياتها
بعض لحظات الصدق حين تختفي الحسابات
السياسيه وحين تغضب الانسانيه على ما
عداها
كان هذا ختام 300 ولكننا نذهب الان الى
اخبار الساعه مع الزميل صهيب بشراير ولديه
ايضا العديد من الاخبار الليله